notre second débat on va changer
totalement de thème et c'est ce qu'on
aime dans cette émission débat consacré
à la crise économique en Chine une
croissance en berne des exportations en
forte baisse un chômage des jeunes qui
explose de nombreux indicateurs sont
dans le rouge le point de départ de
cette crise c'est l'immobilier 2 ans
après la chute du promoteur local
everground un autre géant du secteur qui
s'appelle country Garden étant
difficulté c'est toute l'économie
chinoise qui retient son souffle flore à
sauvage
exportation en berne crise immobilière
les nuages s'amoncellent sur l'économie
chinoise dans les rues de Pékin les fils
de travailleurs intérimaires s'allonge
devant les agences de recrutement depuis
la levée de la politique zéro covid
l'économie de l'Empire du Milieu ne
redémarre pas le mois dernier face au
chômage des jeunes qui ne cesse de
flamber la Chine a cessé de publier les
chiffres mensuels du chômage des moins
de 24 ans près d'InGen urbain sur 5 et
sans emploi je suis très inquiète
lorsque je pense à trouver un emploi je
deviens très anxieuse depuis
l'éclatement de la Bul immobilière le
nombre de ventes ne cesse de chuter avec
une baisse de 34% au mois d'août
plusieurs promoteurs sont au bord de la
faillite à l'image de country Garden
l'un des leaders du secteur qui a
échappé une extrémie à un défaut de
paiement le mois dernier il y a un
risque de crise systémique à l'échelle
de l'économie chinoise puisque si l'une
de ces entreprises ou une série
d'entreprises devaient s'effondrer les
les répliques se feraient ressentir dans
d'autres secteurs de l'économie pour
autant cette expert de l’empire du
milieu estime que le risque de contagion
mondial à l'image de la crise des
subprimes en 2008 est peu probable
pourquoi parce que c'est une crise qui
est finalement qui repose sur des
investissements de l'argent
exclusivement chinois et sur des
secteurs qui sont assez peu
internationalisés comme comme le secteur
de l'immobilier mais le ralentissement
de l'économie chinoise pourrait
toutefois avoir un impact en Europe
parmi les pays les plus exposés la
France l'Allemagne et l'Italie qui
vendent à la Chine des biens
d'équipements des voitures et des
produits pharmaceutiques la crise
économique chinoise doit-elle aussi nous
inquiéter voilà le thème de notre débat
avec Sylvie matelli bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes économiste directrice adjointe
de l'iris Pascal Alizard bonsoir bien
vous êtes sénateur et l'air du Calvados
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et membre de la
commission des affaires européennes au
Sénat et auteur de deux rapports sur sur
la Chine Baptiste falbosse bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes rédacteur en chef à
France 24 ancien correspondant en Chine
je crois que c'était pendant une
demi-douzaine d'années 7 ans et vous
contribuez aussi d'informations
asialistes Laetitia cru paditoris
politique est resté à mes côtés alors on
monte au point de départ cette bulle
immobilière qui a explosé il y a il y a
deux ans la chute de dévergrand dans
quoi cette crise cinématiques elle est
symptomatique du fonctionnement
peut-être du régime chinois de l'État
chinois
elle est symptomatique du fonctionnement
de l'État chinois et de l'économie
chinoise à plusieurs titres premier
titre c'est que c'est un secteur qui est
largement subventionné par les pouvoirs
publics c'est un secteur aussi où les
promoteurs sont en grande partie véreuse
c'est à dire corrompu il y a des pots de
vin il y a des il y a des malversations
qui sont faites et troisième élément
alors troisième élément je pourrais en
citer d'autres mais c'est le fait que on
n'a pas véritablement parce qu'on est en
Chine d'indicateurs d'évolution du
marché donc il y a des bulles
spéculatives qui se forment puis des
promoteurs qui ne sont pas capables
d'achever des constructions enfin il y a
un moment donné ou un autre il y a pas
de de d'indicateurs qui vous dit
attention le secteur entre dans une
crise il faut assainir et bah du coup la
bulle gonfle gonfle jusqu'à exploser ou
à mettre en faillite un certain nombre
de promoteurs et c'est d'autant plus
important le secteur immobilier que ça
représente quand même 25% du PIB chinois
donc on voit que le fait que ce secteur
d'activité et des difficultés ça pèse
sur l'ensemble de cette économie sur
l'ensemble des consommateurs chinois
avec toutes les conséquences que ça peut
avoir c'est un pays de propriétaire la
Chine alors c'est un pays de
propriétaire c'est un pays où
l'immobilier et au fait il est au cœur
de la vie des chinoise c'est vraiment
une obsession pour de très nombreuses
familles acheter un appartement voir un
deuxième voire un troisième quand on a
un enfant il a déjà 5 ans qu'on
réfléchit à l'appartement surtout si tu
as un fils à l'appartement qu'on veut
lui acheter pour qu'il puisse se marier
et c'est une vérité dans de nombreuses
villes chinois ça fait partie du package
le mariage d'appartement donc il se
marie de plus en plus tard mais aussi
pour des raisons financières aussi parce
que certains n'ont pas les moyens
d'acheter justement le fameux
appartement et donc qu'on comprend le
l'ampleur du drame que ça peut être
quand il y a une chute de l'immobilier
comme ça la bulle avait atteint des
proportions absolument délirantes un
exemple à Shanghai je crois que les
derniers chiffres avant qu'elle se
dégonfle on estimait qu'en moyenne pour
avoir un appartement un chinois devait
payer l'équivalent de plus de 40 ans de
salaire à Paris on est autour de 20 ans
à peu près oui donc c'est 40 ans voire
50 ans de salaire donc c'est vraiment à
partir du moment où cette bulle se
dégonfle c'est un cataclysme donc c'est
un appauvrissement alors généraliser le
terme est peut-être un peu fort mais
mais
d'accord puisqu'on a toujours parié sur
une montée de l'immobile j'achète mais
ça va monter à partir du moment où on ne
se sent plus riche entre guillemets il y
a beaucoup de Chinois en ce moment qui
sont tentés de ne plus dépenser pour
tout un tas de raisons et puis certains
vous le disiez à juste titre qui avait
acheté un appartement qui ne peuvent pas
l'habiter qui doivent pourtant
rembourser leur crédit immobilier et
donc ça ça amène des situations
catastrophiques parce qu'ils a est-ce
que vous voyez un effet domino à
l'oeuvre là en ce moment en Chine depuis
cette éclatement de cette bulle
immobilière et que je crois que au
regard des arguments qui viennent déjà
être exposés oui effectivement il y a un
risque de contagion contagion à
l'économie chinoise mais aussi contagion
aux autres pays qui sont en relation
avec la Chine et même si les flux sont
extrêmement déséquilibrés en défaveur de
l'Occident des faveurs de la France il
n'empêche que se ralentissement peut
nous toucher à un moment donné aussi
c'est un pays que vous connaissez bien
vous avez été pendant 25 ans le
vice-président d'un équipementier
automobile beaucoup de business avec
avec la Chine ces deux rapports
sénatoriaux sur la Chine on a souvent
une façon de penser la Chine comment à
l'envers d'une certaine façon qu'est-ce
que vous dites de cela alors ça c'est un
sujet qui effectivement m'a toujours
intéressé et au fil de mes travaux que
ce soit effectivement au niveau
industriel professionnel mais aussi en
tant qu'élu j'ai toujours fait très
attention à ne pas complètement aborder
les problèmes qui nous étaient soumis
avec nos grilles de lecture avec nos
logiciels d'occidentaux parce que je
crois que très rapidement on peut
arriver à de mauvaises conclusions alors
qu'il serait des conclusions justes
selon nos référentiels mais qui
finalement ne sont pas vécus du tout de
cette façon là et ne sont pas ressentis
de cette façon là par les Chinois et par
les dirigeants chinois on est très
étonné de la capacité de régulation qui
ne partent pas de la même de la même
rationalité que nous alors sur cette je
reviens sur cette question
de la bulle immobilière j'espère qu'on
aura pas trop de caricatures
occidentale dans la façon dont parler
mais quand même je crois que c'est 9
chinois sur 10 qui sont qui sont
propriétaires c'est ça donc bon voilà et
certains rappels on a récupéré pas mal
de témoignages autour de cette crise
économique que sont pas des spéculateurs
qui sont touchés par exemple
Propriétaire d'un commerce qui nous dit
qu'il peut tout simplement plus
rembourser son prêt on l'écoute
solution que d'arrêter de rembourser nos
prêts les revenus sont instables les
citoyens ordinaires n'ont pas assez
d'argent pour rembourser non pas le
choix
la grande majorité des Chinois achètent
une maison pour y vivre pas pour la
spéculation immobilière ou pour faire du
profit
la maison n'est pas livrée les acheteurs
doivent louer un logement ça représente
un supplémentaires
s'ils doivent en plus effectuer des
versements mensuels pour leur prêt
immobilier avec leurs revenus ils n'ont
pas la capacité de payer très souvent
on est dans un cas très concret il y a
d'autres témoins on va pas tous vous les
faire écouter mais voilà de de
d'immeubles quand tout simplement pas
été livré la photo qui illustre notre
débat c'est justement un complexe de
d'immeuble d'appartement qui a pas été
achevé Sylvie matelli donc c'est cette
situation il y a quoi il y a des sortes
de villes fantômes en Chine aujourd'hui
oui en tout cas des quartiers fantômes
des immeubles n'ont pas été non pas été
hachés et ne seront pas livrés vous avez
aussi des quartiers ou des personnes
aménage malgré tout alors que le le leur
appartement n'est pas terminé parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autre choix et camp
dans ces immeubles fantômes avec deux
trois appartements qui sont vous avez
toutes ces situations là mais pire que
ça c'est ce que disait ce monsieur c'est
que on rembourse son crédit immobilier
on commence à rembourser alors même que
son appartement n'est pas terminé et que
son appartement perd de la valeur ou en
tout cas pour répandre beaucoup de
valeur parce que la bulle est en train
d'éclater donc c'est ça qui est terrible
en fait dans ce pays alors je sais pas
si c'est un prisme occidental va-t-il
mais est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a
des puisque vous me dites il y a des
comportements de corruption des
promoteurs est-ce qu'il y a la Chine
n'est pas un régime qui peut être très
tendre parfois on va dire ça avec les
citoyens est-ce qu'il y a eu des
condamnations est-ce qu'il y a eu des
peines de prison comment commencer
régler par la justice chinoise dossier
immobilier alors il y a eu des
condamnations alors il y a eu alors le
patron des vergandés si mes souvenirs
sont bons on n'a pas été condamnés il
est encore en poste
pour country Garden je ne saurais contre
regarder c'est le deuxième promotion qui
est en train d'arriver on craint une
faillite de se promener dès qu'on a
nation pour corruption de façon générale
il y en a beaucoup en Chine mais parfois
elles prennent aussi des allures de
purge c'est à dire que on a tendance
parfois à condamner une personne qui
n'est pas spécialement dans son clan
politique dans son voilà dans ses
affiliations on va dire du quotidien
donc oui l'état agi l'état
agit alors il agit également comme il
peut sur je pense notamment la ce qui
s'est passé voyant la bulle se dégonfler
il est en train aussi de baisser enfin
de faciliter l'accès au crédit pour
relancer la machine il y a quand même
une force de frappe de la part du
gouvernement chinois qui est quand même
assez importante et notamment cette
force de frappe s'est faite dans l'autre
sens lorsque la bulle s'est dégonflé
c'est parce qu'il a demandé de
restreindre l'accès au crédit voyant
justement que la bulle était en train de
gonfler gonfler et ça a provoqué
l'effondrement qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est l'une des raisons là il essaye de
relancer la machine pour revenir donc à
votre question dès qu'on a nation oui il
y en a maintenant vous savez c'est pas
un système judiciaire qui est
extrêmement transparent donc voilà ça
peut être aussi prendre des atouts de
règlement politique parfois Laetitia il
y a une expression qui monte depuis deux
ans depuis l'éclatement de cette bulle
immobilière à utiliser par les médias
les experts les analyses c'est le moment
les man expliquez-nous c'est une
expression qui est apparu alors on a
fait notre petite recherche à public
Senna et on a retrouvé elle est apparu
cette expression pour la première fois
dans un tweet daté du 21 septembre 2021
et c'est un des plus grands banquiers
des plus riches banquiers indiens qu'il
l'écrit il le tweet il dit il dit
effectivement ici evergrand était le
moment Lehman de la Chine voilà il le
dit comme ça on l'a traduit comme ça en
français mais c'est un peu un peu ce
qu'il voulait dire et à partir de là
c'est vrai que on se rend compte que le
moment Lehmann ça parle à tout le monde
qu'on soit en Inde qu'on soit en Chine
qu'on soit en France qu'on soit en
Suisse qu'on soit en Espagne on comprend
tous qu'effectivement il peut y avoir un
effondrement systémique et puis
généralisé donc c'est vrai que c'est une
expression qui a tout de suite fait
peuple jusqu'à là en août 18 août
dernier article Wall Street Journal qui
tisserait ça alors on s'est amusé Thomas
à faire une petite infographie on va
aller voir défiler un parce que les
médias se sont jetés sur cette
expression en or pour les médias elle
veut tout dire donc on va voir que de la
Suisse jusqu'aux États-Unis en passant
par l'Allemagne enfin tout les journaux
bien sûr on récupérait cette expression
moment Lehmann et finalement je pense
que tous les lectorats ont compris
référence à la faillite de la banque
américaine les mêmes Brothers c'était en
2008 ça avait déclenché la dernière
grande crise financière mondiale est-ce
qu'on peut faire le voilà le comparatif
justement avec avec le cas et werground
oui parce que c'était deux poids lourds
de l'économie les manprothers c'était la
quatrième banque d'investissement aux
États-Unis et puis vers Granby c'est le
deuxième plus important promoteur
immobilier chinois et en communication
la peur on le sait c'est vraiment le
moteur parfait c'est à dire que dès
qu'on agite la peur et le chiffon rouge
tout le monde comprend le mot
effondrement donc c'est vrai que on
pouvait on pouvait faire cette
similitude et se rapprochement et c'est
ce qu'a fait ce grand banquier indien
les politiques ont repris le mot pour
l'instant c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que les analystes les observateurs
deux ans plus tard reprennent toujours
la même expression et puis les médias
bien sûr mais les politiques pour
l'instant
n'osent pas le faire pourquoi Thomas je
ne sais pas est-ce qu'ils ont peur que
dire ce mot ça va finalement
où c'est le premier domino on ne sait
pas mais pour l'instant ça reste un
récit pour l'instant d'après vous pour
l'instant c'est un récit pourquoi parce
que des observateurs je ne sais pas ce
que vous en pensez au soir juste après
mais c'est vrai que certains disent que
ça n'a rien à voir parce que les
États-Unis ont injecté énormément
d'argent tout de suite à réussir à
sauver quand même ce qui aurait pu être
catastrophique et que finalement
certains observateurs sont unanimes sur
le fait que ce seront simplement les
pays les plus proches les plus vraiment
en commerce direct avec la Chine qui
seront touchées et donc en France
normalement on devrait être par exemple
la France parce que nous sommes en
France épargnés
avec nos spécialistes je commence avec
vous parce que ils arrêtent est-ce que
vous y croyez ce moment Lehmann là dans
ton parle à propos de l'immobilier c'est
une formidable expression parfaitement
marketée ça vient d'être dit par un
banquier indien c'est parfait et donc
effectivement quand on veut porter
atteinte
un concurrent systémique comme la Chine
et je suis pas là pour défendre la Chine
c'est bien joué voilà effectivement
maintenant quand on lit ce qu'il en est
deux ans après de la part plus des
analystes d'ailleurs que des politiques
je suis d'accord avec vous les opinions
sont assez partagées parce que le risque
est l'attend la crise est réelle la
question n'est pas de nier la crise mais
la question c'est de savoir aussi
comment elle peut être régulée je crois
qu'effectivement les États-Unis n'ont
aucun intérêt à ce que cette crise se
développe la Chine ils sont quand même
les premier détenteurs publics de dettes
chinoises donc il faut faire attention à
cela c'est un peu je te tiens tu me
tiens sur ce sujet là on en parle très
très peu souvent et puis effectivement
le gouvernement chinois a quand même des
capacités à réagir qui sont d'ailleurs
des capacités d'un pays autoritaire d'un
pays qui n'est pas démocratique avec des
réactions ultra rapide alors on voit
d'un côté ce que vous avez montré la
réaction du citoyen qui lui
effectivement subit plein fouet le sujet
l'individu et puis après il y a la
régulation politique qui est totalement
différente de ce qu'on peut vivre chez
nous et et à partir de là la notion de
temps aussi qui est plus élastique dans
la mentalité chinoise que chez nous
amortie amortit la chose donc une vraie
crise avec des conséquences fortes et
pour les Chinois et pour chez nous n'est
pas certaine maintenant l'expression
Lehmann c'est parfait je vous rappelle
quand même que c'était aux États-Unis et
j'avais inventé l'amortissement négatif
fallait oser quand même pas dans ce cas
là Sylvie Mathilde est-ce qu'on peut
comparer les les deux catastrophes
économiques
pas vraiment parce que quand on parle de
l'éman Brother on parle d'une banque
donc de la faillite d'une banque quand
on parle des vagues ou de country Garden
on est sur des promoteurs immobiliers
avant que les mêmes Brothers se
retrouvent en difficulté on a eu la
faillite aux États-Unis toute l'année
2000 à partir de l'année 2006 d'ailleurs
donc toute l'année 2006 toute l'année
2007 la faillite d'un certain nombre de
promoteurs immobiliers et puis les
grandes difficultés liées au crédit
subprimes des des acheteurs des
propriétaires américains donc ce n'est
que dans un deuxième temps à l'été de
1000 alors ça a commencé début 2008 mais
les financiers essayaient de masquer les
choses à partir de l'été 2008 on se rend
compte que le système financier
américain et en danger et un certain
nombre de bons américaines sont au bord
a faillite et dans un premier temps
sauvé par les autorités américaines les
mains de Brothers c'est vraiment la pire
des banques avec un patron qui avait
vraiment pas de copain à Washington et
puis à quelques semaines d'une élection
américaine qui est opposée à l'époque
John McCain et Barack Obama avec l'idée
côté républicain qui était au pouvoir
côté bouge si on sauve les mêmes
Brothers donc cette grande banque
d'investissement qui a joué
donc on voit qu'on n'était pas dans le
même contexte puisque ça part d'une
crise immobilière et ça et ça et ça
finit par par une crise
financière est-ce que le même effet
domino se fait deux ou trois fois que si
cette expression peut se reproduire là
avec ce qui se passe en Chine
partent très souvent d'une crise
immobilière pourquoi parce que pour
acheter votre appartement pour acheter
un commerce ou un fonds de commerce vous
vous endettez et donc si vous vous
endettez vous faites intervenir un
banquier qui va prendre un risque en
vous prêtant cet argent le risque c'est
que les prix s'effondre donc bien
évidemment quand vous avez une crise
immobilière et ça c'est pas un moment
Lehman c'est universel quand vous avez
une crise immobilière le risque qu'elle
se transforme en Christ financière et
dans un troisième temps en crise
économique n'est absolument pas nul je
me permets de souligner qu'aujourd'hui
les acteurs financiers mondiaux et je
fais le distingo avec les Chinois les
acteurs financiers mondiaux ils sont
très impactés par l'inflation et on l'a
eu aux États-Unis il y a eu un certain
nombre de difficultés en début d'année
de la part de banquiers américains on a
eu quelques craintes en Europe et les
autorités européennes ont agi très très
vite donc on a des fragilités c'est vrai
dans le système financier dans le
partout dans le monde qui peuvent
entraîner une crise financière on a
vraiment eu cette crainte est-ce que ça
viendra de la Chine j'en sais rien à ce
stade j'en sais rien alors on va essayer
de dézoomer sortir un peu de la crise et
cette bulle immobilière pour regarder
quelques indicateurs de l'activité
économique chinoise qui est quand même
clairement en ralentir regardez les
chiffres des exportations et des
importations les exportations chinoises
chiffres du mois de juillet par rapport
à l'an dernier - 14,5% les importations
moins 12,4% ce sont toujours les
chiffres du mois de juillet 9e mois
consécutive de baisse et on retrouve
pratiquement pas tout à fait mais
pratiquement des chiffres de l'époque
covid ou par définition l'économie
s'était arrêtée parce qu'elle est
bizarre
et encore une fois vous n'êtes pas là
pour défendre l'économie chinoise mais
si on il y a quand même des atouts
inhérents à la fois au régime et à
l'économie chinoise à sa à sa puissance
à son marché intérieur qui peut lui
permettre de surmonter cette cette crise
d'après vous
je pense que oui alors
la crise est là ça personne
ne discute cela
je tire votre attention sur le fait que
c'est pas le seul pays qui connaît la
crise donc bien sûr donc il faudrait pas
non plus quand parlant de ce sujet on se
défaut ce à bas coût de nos propres
problèmes donc je dis ça comme ça moi
j'ai pas de souci parce qu'on a fait
suffisamment de débat sur ce plateau sur
la crise en France et sur l'économie
française mais vous avez raison de le
dire reposer les choses à leur juste
alors juste point
la problématique de leurs exportations
je rappelle que quand la belle tanload a
commencé alors c'est quoi la belle ça la
ceinture et la route ou la route est la
ceinture comme vous voulez voilà donc
c'est quoi les nouvelles routes de la
soie c'est ce qu'on appelle de la
nouvelle vie alors après il y a eu one
Bello dans sa bon bref on a on a à peu
près toutes les appellations il y a
d'ailleurs le ministre en charge du
sujet que j'avais vu il y a quelques
années américains monsieur le sénateur
ne vous inquiétez pas c'est un simple
c'est un simple label économique vous
voyez donc je pourrais vous voilà c'est
c'est pas tout à fait comme ça qu'on
l'avait interprété mais ce que je
voulais simplement dire c'est que dans
cette démarche qui est vraiment une
politique volontariste construite de
l'État chinois il y avait aussi une
démarche de politique intérieure c'était
déjà des régions en faible croissance
avec des risques de soulèvement alors
ils ont d'autres méthodes pour quand
même mater tout ça mais à un moment
donné il faut quand même amener du
pouvoir d'achat il faut amener un peu de
développement et et c'est parti de ça
donc c'était donner des débouchés
économiques à des régions c'est sinistré
en Chine en permettant que les
exportations progressent en France de
l'aménagement du territoire en quelque
sorte et ces créations ça a été aussi
des créations de capacité de
surproduction et à un moment donné il a
bien fallu mais il a bien fallu les bon
là il y a des flux qui se mettent en
place et si ça ralentit ça ralentit mais
pour le moment parce que vous nous avez
donné les chiffres de réduction ils sont
importants moins 14 - 12 mais on reste
quand même sur des chiffres de
progression qui sont significatifs et
parallèlement à ça quand vous regardez
comment évolue le One il est monté il
est redescendu mais on est sur une
valeur aujourd'hui qui est à peu près
celle de 2020 et je dirais cette baisse
finalement elle est plutôt bonne pour
l'économie chinoise c'est un élément de
relance Baptiste falboz est-ce que les
régions dont on parle là qui étaient on
va dire économiquement les plus en
difficulté sont également les plus
impactés par la crise immobilière ou pas
forcément d'ailleurs si visiblement
d'après les chips ça fait partie
effectivement des régions qui sont les
plus touchées je voudrais juste rebondir
sur les sur les chiffres il y a des
nouveaux chiffres qui sont tombés alors
qui pas lié aux exportations aux
importations il y a quelques jours sur
la production industrielle et les ventes
au détail qui montrent comme un léger
frémissement donc voilà je pense qu'il
faut effectivement rester prudent pas
jouer trop vite les Cassandre en disant
attention c'est l'effondrement
généralisé déjà moi-même à l'époque
quand j'étais en Chine donc je suis
arrivé en 2009 jusqu'en 2016 on
prédisait souvent un effondrement disait
c'est pas possible toutes ces villes
fantômes qui poussent comme des
champignons tout va s'effondrer tout va
s'effondrer bon il y a eu des
ralentissements il y a eu des baisses la
celle-ci est quand même bien plus
violente que les précédentes mais c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il faut toujours
rester extrêmement prudent vis-à-vis des
comme ça des verdicts un peu abruptes
sur l'économie chinoise
viennent de l'Occident
tout va passer
chinois tout va bien
c'est pour ça que je rebondissais sur ce
que vous disiez bien sûr il y a des
problèmes si c'est aussi de la
communication les informations je pense
que l'immobilier là c'est on parle de
quelque chose de de conjoncturel après
il y a d'autres défis on en parlera
peut-être plus tard beaucoup plus
structurelles qui attendent la Chine et
c'est la crise démographique bien sûr la
démographie on en parlera évidemment
enfin j'espère parce que le temps file
quand même assez vite mais on parle
finalement des leviers du régime alors
il y a les leviers on va dire positif
mais il y a aussi une forme de reprise
en main par le régime chinois le Parti
communiste pour ne pas le nommer des des
grandes entreprises enfin est-ce que ça
ça fragilise un petit peu le business et
donc l'économie chinoise
en tout cas sa questionne sur le modèle
et sur la stratégie économique du
gouvernement chinois et je rejoins ce
qui a été dit moi je crois que la crise
ou en tout cas le questionnement et je
suis pas sûr que ce ne soit qu'une crise
économique démarre en 2008 avec la crise
de 2008 ou les Chinois se rendent compte
bien avant nous et la pandémie se rendre
compte qu'ils sont peut-être beaucoup
trop dépendants des marchés occidentaux
et en particulier du marché américain et
qui va falloir diversifier tout ça et
diversifier ça a été les routes de la
soie avec la volonté non seulement de
diversifier le développement économique
de ce pays en les tendant à des régions
reculées mais aussi la même la stratégie
des routes de la soie valait pour le
voisinage de de la Chine donc l'Asie
centrale puis pour l'Afrique voire un
peu plus tard pour l'Amérique latine
avec cette idée on va utiliser notre
force de frappe pour rapidement aller
démarcher à les conquérir des nouveaux
marchés qui vont venir compenser le les
marchés occidentaux un chiffre que
j'aime bien rappeler en 2012 les
échanges Sud donc les échanges entre
pays du Sud ont été égaux aux échanges
entre le Nord et le Sud et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que jusque là on était
plutôt dans du 80/20 c'est à dire les
pays du Nord très très riche acheter 80
% des exportations mondiales et les pays
du Sud se cantonnaient au 20% et les 50%
ils ont été en grande partie le fait de
cette stratégie chinoise avec l'idée on
va aussi passer un nouveau modèle un
modèle ou pour augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat de la population je vous
rappelle qu'une des mesures qui avait
été prise par le gouvernement chinois
après la crise de 2008 et pour compenser
l'impact de la crise ça avait été
d'augmenter les salaires de 40%. c'est
pareil vous en parlerez autour de vous
mais je pense que ça ferait plaisir à
beaucoup de monde donc 40% il faut les
payer il faut les financer en économie
quand on veut financer une augmentation
de salaire bon on monte en valeur
ajoutée donc on monte en compétences en
investit dans la technologie et en plus
ça peut permettre de développer la
croissance économique donc on est
vraiment dans toutes on est vraiment
dans toute cette dimension et en fait ce
dont on s'aperçoit ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que si tout ce
questionnement et ce virage du modèle a
commencé en 2008 ça veut dire qu'on est
dans une évolution structurelle de ce de
ce modèle économique avec en particulier
une crainte et ça ça apparaît un tout
petit peu plus tard avec l'arrivée au
pouvoir de CGT avec une crainte de
reproduire parce que l'économie s'est
développée on va la faire monter en
gamme est-ce que on ne risque pas un
modèle Union soviétique qui s'effondre
le modèle il y a des personnes qui se
sont enrichies qui commencent à prendre
un certain nombre de liberté à donner
des leçons rappelez-vous jackma a donné
des leçons d'économie simping est-ce que
on ne risque pas si on le laisse faire
et si on ouvre cette boîte de Pandore de
voir le régime politique cette fois-ci
s'effondrer et donc effectivement la
reprise
avec quand même il faut à ce moment du
débat peut-être dire prononcer le mot
covid parce que à quel point le le
l'épidémie
de covid et la stratégie chinoise
à bloquer ou fragiliser cette stratégie
que vous êtes en train de nous expliquer
depuis un moment
le zéro covid a laissé des traces alors
je pense que déjà il a laissé une espèce
de désillusion par rapport au pouvoir
politique on entend souvent dire la
population est en ébullition c'est très
très difficile de le savoir des gens
n'est pas qu'au quotidien en Chine il y
a un milliard 400 millions de Chinois
donc on peut pas faire un portrait comme
ça de la Chine rapide en tout cas moi
des contacts que j'ai encore en Chine
une sorte de fatalisme vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique cette politique du
zéro covid ou finalement tout le pays a
été claque muré et surtout vers la fin
pendant plusieurs mois pour qu'au final
il s'ouvre d'un coup que tout le monde
se soit contaminé et pourquoi avoir vécu
comme ça sous cloche pendant trois ans
pour obtenir finalement le même résultat
que les pays occidentaux sachant que
c'est un pays qui avait quand même
communiqué justement sur sa stratégie du
Zéro covid donc vous avez une économie
qui a été à l'arrêt car redémarrer avec
des espoirs de relance tout azimut une
fois que le pays s'est rouvert et là on
est dans une deuxième vague qui est
plutôt descendante cette fois ci d'un
point de vue économique pour revenir sur
ce que vous disiez c'est intéressant
aussi on est dans un pays où aujourd'hui
c'est la loyauté à chez Jinping qui
compte parfois même avant peut-être la
compétence on l'a vu lors du dernier
congrès du Parti communiste ou c'est
vraiment le clan de chez jimping qui a
sécurisé les postes les plus importants
du pouvoir et d'après effectivement un
certain nombre d'analyses ça peut aussi
vouloir dire une certaine paralysie on
ne veut pas déplaire au chef on ne veut
pas prendre d'initiative on ne veut pas
faire des réformes osées et ce risque de
paralysie c'est souvent brandi vous
parlez de soviétisation
en disant est-ce que les gens auront le
courage de prendre des réformes
volontaires qui sont en rupture mais
effectivement alors je reste sur un peu
la même question parce que Lisa c'est
vrai que quand on est chef d'entreprise
si enfin
ça incite pas beaucoup à l'innovation et
à la prise de risque s'il y a la le
Parti communiste chinois juste au-dessus
de vos têtes qui vous dit ben non c'est
fini vous avez peut-être pouvoir
disparaître comme ça
pendant des jours voir des semaines etc
etc donc c'est intéressant de voir
l'impact que ça peut avoir sur le
finalement le développement de
l'économie chinoise qui était qui
faisait de plus en plus la part belle à
l'innovation à la prise de risque etc
etc qu'est-ce que vous en pensez mais je
crois que la part belle à l'innovation
est au risque existe toujours continue
ça continue mais dans un environnement
extrêmement contrôlé dans chaque
entreprise je n'ai pas contradictoire ça
nous paraît contradictif
chez eux c'est comme ça et si vous
voulez faire du business avec eux il
faut bien s'y adapter dans votre
entreprise que ça vous plaise ou non
vous avez le délégué du Parti communiste
auquel vous rendez des cons et quand il
vous fait une injonction il est quand
même de bon ton de l'écouter et de voir
comment on peut on peut s'adapter alors
chez nous ça paraît à des années lumière
de notre façon de fonctionner chez eux
ça fonctionne comme ça et il faut bien
constater là on parle de l'immobilier
mais sur tout un tas de secteurs de
l'industrie vous avez des entreprises
synthèse étrangère qui sont implantés ça
fonctionne et leur propre entreprise
fonctionnent très correctement et avec
je dirais des niveaux d'innovation des
niveaux de productivité qui sont dans
nos standards il y a plus de différence
il y a 20 ans on y allait parce qu'on
voulait trouver du bas coût il y avait
peut-être 20 ans d'écart sur les
technologies utilisées tout ça c'est
fini alors c'est dans ce contexte que
l'Europe essaye de se défendre contre
j'allais dire l'invasion mais le bruit
de certaines trop fort contre le
l'arrivée de plus en plus importantes de
véhicules électriques chinois je propose
à Audrey brittaz de nous rejoindre sur
ce plateau parce que on va faire le
point justement sur ce cette enquête
rebond soit Audrey lancée par l'Union
européenne sur les subventions publiques
chinoises aux entreprises automobiles
oui c'est la présence de la commission
Ursula fentherlayenne qui a fait cette
annonce mercredi dernier lors de son
discours sur l'état de l'Union écouté
les marchés mondiaux sont désormais
inondés de voitures électriques
chinoises moins chères dont le prix est
maintenu artificiellement bas par
d'énormes subventions publiques cela
fausse notre marché
imaginez en 2021 la Chine c'était moins
de 1% du marché de l'électrique en
Europe aujourd'hui on parle aux deux
chiffres autour de 8% l'enquête va
permettre de vérifier si cette rapide
ascension respecte bien les règles de la
concurrence et si la Chine ne
subventionne pas trop ces véhicules avec
des aides sur les matières premières sur
la fabrication de batterie sur
l'assemblage et même sur l'énergie
certains observateurs estiment en tout
cas que les voitures chinoises
arriveraient en Europe 20% moins cher
que les véhicules d'autres nationalités
est-ce un coup de main de l'État c'est
ce qu'il faut déterminer Thomas ont déjà
mis en place des des mesures pour
protéger leur filière automobile on peut
se demander pourquoi
l'Europe n'a pas été aussi vite est-ce
que l'Europe protège aussi bien sa
filière en fait il y a des dissensions
au niveau européen l'Allemagne a fait de
la Chine un partenaire commercial
privilégié en 2019 tenez-vous bien 40%
des ventes de Volkswagen s'effectuer en
Chine a été donc très frileuse à lancer
une telle enquête vers son partenaire
financier à l'inverse la la France qui
aimerait bien développer une filière de
l'automobile électrique faisait pression
auprès de Bruxelles pour que ce bras de
fer s'enclenche écoutez d'ailleurs la
réaction très positive de Bruno Le Maire
le ministre de l'Économie après les
annonces de la présidente de la
commission
pour être compétitif il faut innover il
faut simplifier nos règles mais il faut
aussi savoir défendre nos intérêts et
l'Europe doit montrer qu'elle est
déterminée à défendre ses intérêts
économiques à défendre ses intérêts
industriels de ce point de vue là
l'ouverture de cette enquête est une
très bonne décision que je tiens à
saluer alors pourquoi cette enquête et
bien si elle met en lumière des
infrasions aux règles mondiales du
commerce l'Europe pourrait infliger des
droits de douane punitifs aux véhicules
chinois ils sont actuellement de 10% ils
pourraient passer à 20% l'annonce en
tout cas est prise au sérieux à la fée
reculer les constructeurs chinois en
boursement merci beaucoup Sylvie Matili
est-ce que vous croyez assez à ces
sanctions européennes dans dans le
climat de dissension franco-allemande
dont on parlait alors dans le climat de
dis dont on parlait on pourrait imaginer
que l'Union européenne accepte enfin
puis s'imposer ces sanctions là si un
règlement de l'OMC le lui permettait
c'est-à-dire s'il y avait une pleine qui
était déposé à l'OMC par l'Union
européenne tout à fait l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce contre la Chine vu
la situation aujourd'hui des aides
publiques et des investissements publics
dans le secteur de l'automobile
électrique je doute qu'on prenne ce
risque là parce que on se mettrait aussi
au risque que les Chinois nous attaquent
entre suivant et qui plus est je pense
que la situation est bien plus
compliquée aujourd'hui ce qu'on observe
sur la Chine dans la mutation que
constitue voire la révolution que
constitue la transition énergétique
c'est que la Chine
et est un pays extrêmement pollueur
émetteur de CO2 mais qui a compris très
très tôt ce qu'elle est entraîner les
perspectives de neutralité carbone et
donc cette transition énergétique et
qu'elle a pris ses dispositions très tôt
pour sécuriser toutes les chaînes
d'approvisionnement en particulier de
manière première de la transition
énergétique et c'est je pense bien plus
pour ça alors c'est aussi pour les
subventions mais encore une fois tout le
monde subventionne donc je suis pas sûr
que ça fasse une différence totale je
pense que c'est parce qu'elle a su aller
négocier des accords dans le dans le
projet des routes de la soie dont on
parlait tout à l'heure avec un certain
nombre de pays africains par exemple
qu'elle a donc c'est le seul pays
aujourd'hui sur tous les métaux
stratégiques pour la transition
énergétique c'est le seul pays qui
maîtrise toute la chaîne de valeur
depuis quasiment la mine jusqu'à la
production de batterie ou la production
de véhicules électriques et ça c'est une
force de frappe énorme on se souvient
rappelez-vous au printemps dernier c'est
le c'est les dirigeants de la République
Démocratique du la RDC République
démocratique du Congo qui était allée
renégocier avec la Chine parce qu'il
trouvait qu'ils avaient accordé des des
concessions sur les mines qui étaient
beaucoup trop avantage dans un contexte
où les prix augmentés finalement il
s'était fait avoir la Chine a répondu
non c'est trop tard parce que Isa je me
souvenez-vous parce que l'un des deux
rapports dont je parlais tout à l'heure
ça concerne justement ce que l'Union
européenne peut peut faire pour on va
dire quoi rééquilibrer les relations
commerciales avec la Chine le deuxième
rapport le titre c'était la France
peut-elle contribuer au réveil européen
face à la Chine très très explicite et
effectivement dans nos 14 préconisations
il y avait au moins au moins une
meilleure connaissance du régime des
subventions je suis complètement
d'accord plein tout pas plainte et
conséquences collatérales d'une plainte
soyons prudents mais au moins ayons une
bonne connaissance du régime des
subventions vous parlez là effectivement
des véhicules électriques on pourrait
parler du subventionnement des
conteneurs c'est quand même un vrai
sujet on pourrait parler du
photovoltaïque et puis dernier point
parce que ça vient d'être développé mais
la Chine contrôle 80% des terres rares
dans le monde donc à un moment donné par
rapport aux évolutions de protection de
l'environnement qu'on veut avoir et de
développement durable il va falloir
s'interroger parce qu'effectivement on
nous présente ça comme des énergies
renouvelables propres dans des
conditions quand même de production et
d'extraction qui sont parfois
discutables avec le travail des enfants
dont on parle très peu alors je voudrais
donner d'autres chiffres
macroéconiques sur le le la situation en
Chine celui du taux de chômage
maintenant on va faire un focus sur le
chômage chiffre de juillet 2023 pour
toute la population active 5,3% et alors
si on focus si on se concentre sur les
plus jeunes les 16 24 ans
21,3% ce sont des chiffres du mois de
juin on écoute la réaction d'une
étudiante à l'université et on débat
autour de ces chiffres
je suis très inquiète lorsque j'y pense
chercher un emploi trouver un emploi ça
me rend très anxieuse je ne veux pas y
penser pour l'instant j'ai encore
quelques années d'études devant moi un
témoins je l'ai dit pour le chômage déjà
les chiffres il date de juin pourquoi
parce que les autorités elles ont décidé
de suspendre la publication ça dit tout
du malaise autour du chômage des jeunes
quoi
les les critères qu'elles utilisaient
pour ce chômage des jeunes ça veut
beaucoup dire il y a clairement une gêne
de la part des autorités ce chômage de
masse est quelque chose auquel les
jeunes n'étaient pas habitués en plus on
se retrouve avec des jeunes qui sont
très diplômés de plus en plus diplômés
qui sont confrontés à la perspective
d'avoir des des petits boulots en fait
qui ne l'acceptent pas et il y a une
espèce de résignation alors qu'on a
connu aussi un petit peu nous enfin
qu'on connaît en accident aujourd'hui on
parle de grande démission aux États-Unis
en France je sais pas exactement ce
qu'on dit mais il y a ce fatalisme qui
gagne une partie de la jeunesse encore
une fois c'est très difficile de
l'évaluer mais il y a ce mouvement qu'on
appelle le tant ping joui par exemple en
Chine qui est faire la planche
d'ailleurs fait la planche j'arrête je
ne dépense plus d'énergie je ne cherche
pas un travail je fais la planche je
m'allonge je me prends en photo je me
mets sur les ce qui est assez subversif
quand même parce que je je crois qu'il y
a eu des censures de photos de gens qui
faisaient la planche mais ça en dit
beaucoup en fait sur cette société qui
n'est plus dans le développementalisme
absolu en fait mais c'est intéressant
parce que derrière c'est ces
questions-là on ne parlait
d'appauvrissement enfin voilà de
d'incapacité à payer ces
emprunts etc le chômage vous l'avez un
peu évoqué mais bouillonnement social ou
pas crise sociale ou pas qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire difficile franchement je pense
que celui qui a une boule de cristal et
qui capable de dire parce que c'est
pareil des des révoltes en Chine on en
annonce régulièrement en disant le
gouvernement ne pourra pas tenir ça va
ça va péter on l'a dit à la fin du covid
quand il a commencé à avoir ses
manifestations des PagesBlanches des
gens qui protestaient contre le
confinement ça a été très vite endigué
notamment avec aussi un coup de un
serrage de vie très fort des autorités
oui mais enfin la fin de la politique
zéro covid c'est quand même aussi un peu
je pense
une grande un embrasement social c'est
non vous êtes d'accord non je pense que
c'est aussi un besoin c'est qu'il y a
besoin d'avoir des enfants en Chine
parce qu'il y en a pas parce qu'il y a
une crise démographique qui qui émerge
alors juste pour finir c'est très
difficile de savoir ce qui va se passer
entre résignation révolte bon vous avez
quand même un parti qui est absolu et
qui contrôle tout d'une main de fer et
puis il faut pas oublier que la
révolution dans l'histoire de la Chine
en tout cas contemporaine ça s'est
toujours très mal passé ça c'est fini
dans un bain de sang et ça c'est
vraiment je pense à la Révolution
culturelle ce mode saison je pense à
manifestations tiennent à demain en 1989
et dans la psyché collective chinoise
quand même en général une des premières
choses que les parents disent leurs
enfants c'est ne te mêle pas de
politique soit pragmatique fait des
affaires réussis ta vie ne te mêle pas
de politique donc voilà je bien heureux
qui peut prédire ce qui va se passer
elle est juste voilà en tout cas la
crise démographique alors j'y viens la
crise de démographie c'est vraiment
sérieux taux de natalité en 2022 1,15
enfants par femme tient là aussi je vous
propose de d'écouter un témoignage c'est
un citoyen chinois
c'est anonyme il parle de pression pour
faire des enfants écoutons
il y a beaucoup de pression pour avoir
des enfants qui osent avoir des enfants
le taux de chômage est si élevé le covid
a tout détruit il n'y a rien à faire
l'année prochaine nous aurons à nouveau
une croissance en baisse si c'est vrai
que quand on se souvient de ce qui était
la politique chinoise en matière de
natalité c'est elle sait quoi
occidentalisée la société chinoise
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire ah non il y
a eu la politique de l'enfant unique qui
fait que quand vous vouliez avoir un
deuxième enfant il fallait commencer par
payer une amende et alors pour trois
enfants il fallait vraiment être très
riche ça s'est arrêté il y a trois
étapes au début on a autorisé en fait
les deux parents qui étaient en forme
unique avaient droit d'avoir un deuxième
enfant ça c'était dans les années 2000
après on a dit allez si un seul les deux
parents et enfants uniques vous avez
droit d'avoir un deuxième enfant et ça
s'est fait de façon graduelle mais en
fait de la vie de nombreuses
observateurs pas assez vite il fallait
aller beaucoup plus vite est-ce que
c'est pas là le finalement la principale
faiblesse de l'économie chinoise à terme
clairement avec en plus une population
qui vieillit et une population qui
vieillit et qui n'a pas les systèmes de
retraite dont nous pouvons disposer nous
donc vous avez une une population qui
n'a eu qu'un enfant et qui compte
vraiment sur cet enfant pour quand on
sera trop âgé pouvoir survivre pour voir
vivre correctement garder à peu près son
niveau de vie sauf que et ça se ça se ça
se correlle avec le chômage des jeunes
c'est que ce chômage des jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est ce que ça dit sur les
retraites ce qui est assez amusant comme
quand vous voyagez en Chine sur des
sites touristiques c'est que vous ne
voyez que des personnes âgées parce que
ces personnes âgées se vieillissement de
la population c'est géré comme ça par
les autorités c'est à dire on les fait
voyager on leur fait visiter la Chine en
leur monde combien c'est formidable ce
pays et puis ça en remet on remet envie
des sites des sites touristiques mais
une s'il y a crise économique ou s'il y
a une baisse des revenus d'une
population âgée qui va être de plus en
plus âgée bien ça va ça va plus être
possible et là
une histoire que l'on raconte et qui
rend la retraite plutôt plutôt
j'allais dire plutôt belle je suis pas
sûr qu'elle soit belle la retraite mais
en tout cas qui fait que les personnes
âgées aujourd'hui sont heureuses d'être
d'être âgés ça risque de se tarifs
est-ce que vous parlez de bombardements
avec cette démographie chinoise je pense
que c'est impression je me suis
complètement d'accord avec un point
c'est aussi le déséquilibre de
population entre les hommes et les
femmes parce que la politique de
l'enfant unique a généré l'élimination
d'un certain nombre de bébés filles et
pour relancer la natalité il faut quand
même deux et il y a un vrai déséquilibre
dans le dans
de natalité féminine et à partir de là
c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus long pour
relancer un cycle de développement
normal
ne veulent pas le deuxième enfant mais
je veux rester parce que le contexte
économique est trop ponctionnelle et
parce enfants coûte extrêmement cher
c'est un phénomène quasiatique attention
c'est pareil en Corée du Sud c'est
pareil Hong Kong c'est pareil au Japon
en Chine ils se sont habitués à cette
politique de l'enfant unique et
finalement le fait d'avoir un seul
enfant ça voulait dire pour beaucoup de
familles il ne faut pas se rater sur son
éducation on a qu'une seule chance d'en
faire un futur génie qui va financer nos
retraites et donc ils ont dépensé des
sommes folles pour leurs enfants
absolument dingue et donc aujourd'hui
ils ne peuvent pas dupliquer cette
dépense en gros pour deux enfants donc
la politique de l'enfeu unique a eu cet
effet pervers en fait qu'elle allait-y
je vous en prie 30 secondes pour
conclure avec juste un petit un petit
élément qui est assez intéressant c'est
que si votre premier enfant est une
fille aujourd'hui vous pouvez envisager
d'en avoir un deuxième parce qu'une
fille ça coûte pas cher parce que il y
en a beaucoup elle se marient facilement
il y aura pas besoin de lui acheter un
appartement pour qu'elle puisse se
marier etc etc donc c'est assez amusant
ces contradictions en fait de ce modèle
chinois merci beaucoup c'était
proportionnalité
regardez ce qui se passe avec la
démographie allemande et sur l'économie
vous avez pratiquement le même problème
donc c'est pas spécifique à la Chine
c'est ce qu'on a essayé de dire dans ce
débat merci beaucoup merci à tous d'y
avoir participé je vous dis à bientôt
sur public c'est na voilà c'est la fin
de ce numéro de sens public je vous
donne rendez-vous demain 18h 22h sur
notre antenne et puis notez que l'invité
Dorian Mancini demain à 8h ce sera
Alexis Corbière le député la France
insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis belle
soirée à toutes et à tous